yay it's Lily Amy just back in my house
it's so exciting
goose is also gay what up goose it is
September which means back to school
which means sorry and one of the most
iconic back to school or high school
movies of all time is Mean Girls
oh yeah so I thought it'd be really fun
today for us to play something that I
hate which is casting directors I
thought it'd be fun for us to recast the
movie with youtubers in all of the roles
are you game for it I'm so gay okay
we're gonna do all of the main rules so
we're gonna cast them individually and
then we'll turn this back on and go
through who we chose for each part of
which we remembered none of those people
thank you google yes thank you Google
has been more intense than any test I've
ever spent I know this was really
difficult Oh hard
we need to preface these castings none
of this is mean-spirited this is all in
the spirit of fun yes and this isn't
serious we love all the people who are
gonna mention yeah the great thing about
this movie though is I feel like every
character does have great quality they
just get overshadowed buying them worse
quality real they're in a movie they're
made up yeah they don't exist first up
we have Katy okay we did you say I chose
Hannah Hart ah
I chose grace me yeah for several
reasons I feel like you have to be the
Lea or it won't be successful I also
feel like Linds alone have that like
slight awkward in this tour that word
for an I feel like that works yes yes
yes yes yes did she fall in a trash can
why Hanna Hanna because someone that's
trying to figure out where she fits in
that's whoa very smart and has a lot of
knowledge but is sometimes afraid to
tell you how smart she is but then when
she
afraid tells you too much how smart she
is okay I'm good Jeana George I said
Tyler I feel like yeah that's the
obvious choice however I chose
mirandasings okay yes I understand why I
think it would be hilarious and she is
better than everyone else
try me I'd like to thank the one person
who has always been there for me you
were my rock my save you want I'd like
to thank myself yeah well I said Tyler
because he's just fabulous and she was
fabulous and they're both fabulous miss
Norbury who was Tina Fey in the movie
teacher the awkward teacher yeah I chose
Hank green I took dump really yeah and
it's perfect
thank you for your awkward educational
resource the first time ever my
jung-geun was on a red carpet uh-huh he
came up to me first time I said Lilly
there's people screaming my name tell
them just die yet yeah don't use so
awkward and wonderful no I was like yes
this is you okay Karen Karen is Regina
George's more aloof sidekick I think
she's got a heart of gold uh-huh I chose
joy Graceffa because I got you a good
one is Jo incredibly sweet and they both
have really great smiles in really great
hair and I appreciate Jovi's boobs can
tell you when it's gonna rain probably i
toasted that thought was kind of obvious
but not because she's stupid but I said
Miranda just because muraayn was really
silly about it but yeah the second the
boobs thinking I should get a porno oh
oh oh
kind of pull your lucky wieners yeah
Gretchen wieners
I chose Shane Dawson I that's wonderful
but because the click would then meet
Miranda sings Joey and Shane nice and I
felt like that felt like a great me my
metier I chose jenna Marbles ah because
I feel like she would have that ability
to be sassy but like really has a heart
of bullying care sometimes yeah are you
not entertained Lacey Chabert has had a
long career so is that her name's yeah
hurt yes okay miss
George played by Amy Poehler in the film
hmm I put may my heart I hope Avery I
feel like that's a given
Janice now see Janice and Damien were a
team of outsiders so I have two
different choices from Ty different team
okay what one team is you and Kingsley
you Janice
Kingsley Damien and then the second team
is Tyler Oakley Janice Cory Cole Damien
okay she has a whole scenario I have a
whole thing I've got Hannah because I
feel like Hannah would be that
rebellious like you can't tell me this
I'm my own person and then for Damien I
also put Kings we went to put Kingsley
plus vodka so all not Kingsley is drunk
would he be like Damien I know from
experience and then another person a
foot secondary Anthony just because
they're bombs oh I brought my ID so like
he would be that SAS King yes he would
Anthony I know this from the party I
just went to Mahan thing he was just
slaying the dance floor
oh you can't not you can't know you
slide back you get down and you
checkmate on that [ __ ] last but not
least is Erin who is the love interest
and some with the homeboy yeah I put
this person under no basis of who Katie
was because I put you as Katie sure I
put this person because I think he's
really cute did you put Ryan oh he got
you got yep yeah I think that works for
you put this person because they seem to
have a little bit in line with the
character of like being a good person
and then also based on Katie being
Hannah Hart I put I just in Oh feel like
Ryan would also like be that charming
guy turn around like oh yeah this is how
you solve the problem and like you know
the math yeah and I'm like okay you're
right
2+2 a 7 the imagine if Justine turned
around to you was like oh here you go
you're just like your skin and your eyes
here are my life savings on my first
child there are our youtuber casts for
the movie Mean Girls if you disagree or
agree like : blow lands yeah and make
sure you guys go over to the lease
channel and check it out we did a video
over there that may
may not be a hole doing Munoz doing no
way the way the way and across all
social media hi I superwoman I I that's
the one
and thanks let me be on your channel
thanks for being here see you next time
I don't know same face shape is Rhett so
I was like nailed it up at Tim Meadows
and imagine him that's right but that
face is right at Tim Meadows it's retina
great at this point of the editing put
both pictures here you'll see that the
face shape is right